this happened when I was a young
associate in the project that I worked
on and specifically my area of
responsibility on that project just did
not go away we didn't really make
progress on the topics that we are
supposed to work on the client of course
noticed that and after a couple of weeks
he was unhappy and unsatisfied and he
started to critique our world towards me
towards us towards the team and of
course towards the partners as I was the
responsible associate for that specific
piece of work on the team of course I
was very quickly in the focus of the
critique there were also several factors
at least I felt like were out of my
control at the time that contributed to
the overall bad situation but in the end
whatever the reasons were the result was
that it came to a point that pretty much
every single day I was told both by
clients and also our team or our
partners that I was doing something
wrong and this for me at that time was
an immensely stressful situation I
remember Sunday evening sitting at home
feeling literally sick to my stomach
just thinking about on Monday needing to
fly in again to expose myself to the
whole situation